often here um today i want to talk a
little bit about google plus and social
networks
um
i'm not i don't really understand how
these different social networks
um
work
uh because there's just so much
time involved in in trying to keep up
with
all your friends on different networks
and what they're saying and so forth and
so on but i still believe that i mean
everyone is talking about them and using
them so i have to try and figure out how
to make them effective
uh google plus strikes me as quite
interesting because of their hangouts
and so i wish to begin by saying that
i'm going to be involved in three
hangouts this weekend
uh well starting friday night one in
japanese so
i'm gonna hang out
vancouver
there's no day
so one japanese one chinese
and one very interesting one that's
hosted by david manseray
who
is a gentleman that i have communicated
with from time to time i've never met
but he's uh sort of
one of uh this group that you find on
the internet that talks about language
learning and
he has invited a number of uh
polyglots
to talk about
how they learn languages what works for
them and and so forth so you can find
information about all three hangouts at
the link page lingq
at google plus
and i think in order to
be able to participate you have to
include or you have to i think plus one
and include
in the case of the link events link in
your circles
and in the case of david's i think you
have to
include david in your circles i'm not
entirely sure how this all works but i'm
sure some of you who are more tech savvy
than i am can figure it out
and uh the way it works is that google
plus allows you to have up to nine
people plus the moderator actually
visible on
the screen
but the conference can be broadcast to
many many more people who can also send
questions in
and i broadcast mine through
youtube which i think is the only way
because google owns youtube
that you can broadcast them and then
they become videos as some of you may be
aware as you've seen
that some of the recent hangouts have
ended up as videos on my channel
so that's to let you know that there are
these google plus hangouts if you're
interested
um
i think it's it's amazing i still can't
get over the fact that you can have
people from
three or four different continents
talking
around a computer screen
and sharing common interest and so forth
i think that's truly
truly wonderful
and i'm sure people will find more and
more amazing ways
to use this technology
we also started a community a link
community at google plus again these are
all from my perspective experimental i
don't know where this will lead us
you know
there is a limited amount of time you
can spend on a computer
communicating via computer although
if you're looking at the person on the
screen it's it's a you know you are
communicating i i talk to my tutors
in russian today and i'm going to be
speaking russian tomorrow and checked
the other day and and i'm looking at
people and we're talking
and so it is it is amazing really i've
been working on my korean as well and i
don't think i'm that far away from
being able to start speaking to someone
in korean if
any of you want to talk to me in korean
i i would love to talk to you that is
native speakers
but i prefer to do it via link so if
there are
koreans out there who are studying other
languages and want to get on to link and
want to offer discussions at link i will
certainly sign up and become your
student
so there you have it that's really all i
wanted to say today thank you for
listening